[Music]
chuck
what's up neil we're back yes we are
time time for some more knowledge that
you didn't think you needed
is that a positive thing or is that yeah
i don't know i've been thinking about it
that's a very good thing it's always
good to have knowledge
that you didn't think you need because
then you realize wow i need that i need
that in my life
okay so you've all heard you and others
for sure have heard of wind chill factor
yes
okay what is your understanding of wind
chill factor
okay so you know they stopped calling it
that
they now call it the real feel
temperature
okay that's what they call it now all
the meteorologists they call it the
real so they say it's uh
it's uh 28 degrees uh but with the
and then they say this but with the wind
chill the real field temperature
is 15 or more minus three gotcha gotcha
okay so that's
that's an accurate completely correct
understanding of our concept of wind
chill factor okay
so i just want to explain why there is
such a thing as a wind chill factor
okay okay so your body has a skin
temperature it's about
97 degrees or so fahrenheit so
if you have just air sitting above your
skin okay
your your skin is 97 degrees around
there
plus or minus and air is typically
cooler than that unless you live in
like texas right someplace where it's
always very very hot and i'll get back
to that in a minute
but usually the air is cooler than your
skin so
now they worry because if the
temperature gets very cold out
watch what happens you you go out expose
some skin
and let's say it's 32 degrees you'll
feel cold
fine and that's the air above your skin
is removing heat from your skin that's
why you feel cold
something is taking heat away from you
and it's the air
the air sitting above your skin will be
systematically drawing heat away from
your body
okay if your body is losing heat you
will feel cold
where it's having you lose heat okay
that makes sense
it makes sense right so the air is
taking heat away but the air is just
sort of sitting there doing that
right the 32 degree air by the way
that's why i don't wear chaps in the
winter time but go ahead
okay that's why good reason among others
i would suspect
okay so now watch what happens if there
is a breeze
then the air that had just pulled heat
out of you
is now swapped with fresh 32 degree air
oh oh okay
so previously the heat that came out of
your body warmed the air above it
right just a little bit just a little
bit so
what that feels like is what we say 32
degree air
feels like right it's the combination of
this
now a breeze comes wind comes
and that air gets shifted off fresh cold
air comes in and now that's taking heat
out
okay so it's if this keeps up
the air is pulling heat out of your body
at the same rate that colder air would
be taking it out of your body if it was
stationary
wow so you do that calculation
and you find out and i don't have the
the tables in front of me so let's make
up some numbers
that can be you know sensible for this
example by the way that's my favorite
kind of science
makeup numbers i'm not you i just make
it up
yeah you can check this out on table i
don't have it like stuck in my head
but what you can say is air at a certain
speed growing up
let's say 10 miles per hour across my
skin
at 32 degrees is like
air at 23 degrees that's not perfectly
still
that's perfectly still exactly that is
by the way okay
full disclosure now i thought this was
not even going to be that interesting
this is really interesting i mean
this is really cool because it makes so
much sense
see i told you it's knowledge you didn't
even know you needed but go ahead
continue
i'm fascinated okay so now now
just while we're there yeah and this
wasn't really the subject of this
conversation but we're there so i'm
going to throw it in well you got me now
um air is much less dense
than water okay obviously right okay
all right much less dense by like a
factor of a thousand or
multiple high hundreds okay i forgot the
number but you can do the math
if you compare the densities there's a
factor there okay
so that means when you're touching air
many fewer molecules are
interacting with your skin right than if
you if it was water touching
right if i have a mixture of water and
ice
right that will be 32 degrees okay
it just will be that's how that works
out yes if i plunge your hand
into that and keep your other hand out
in the air
at 32 degrees your hand in the water and
the icy water will freeze faster than
your hand and the air will
i i that's i guess what i knew you were
going to say that
but this is the first time that it
actually made sense to me it made sense
because many more molecules are touching
you to take this to suck the heat out of
your body
so you have more molecules on the
surface of your skin
to actually pull away the heat that's so
cool
correct and that is why you just
explained something to me that i've
always accepted always understood to be
true never really questioned it because
it's just
it's one of those things that you just
know that happens
when you want to make something cold you
have a can of beer or
soda or a bottle you don't just stick it
in
ice you stick it in icy
water or water that is bet better than
icy water
you put it in icy water that's somehow
moving
and it will get colder so much quicker
correct so in other words you can put a
a your champagne in the refrigerator
where it's only touching air
or put it in an ice bucket where if it's
only just touching solid ice
but there's still air between the solid
ice add water to it
now you have fruit you have 32 degree
water
and by the way if you want to get it
even colder than that
you put salt on the ice it melts the ice
at the temperature the ice is so the
ice could be 20 to 25 degrees it'll melt
the ice at 25 degrees you have 25 degree
water
and now you put it in and you you jiggle
it as you do
right like that yes and then you're
you're you're basically creating a a
liquid
cool chill factor so okay but it's also
why
if i can send you out butt naked into 35
degree air
okay you could run around for a while
now you can even
pump some energy it'll be cold and
uncomfortable right but
we'll find you alive at two hours later
no you'll find me dead of embarrassment
okay that's what you'll find me i throw
you into 35 degree
water right you're you're you're you're
comatose in 15 minutes
yeah you're done you're done right yeah
okay it's the same temperature
it's a matter of who's pulling heat away
from you the most effectively
that's amazing great so that's the
foundation here but that's not the point
of this
conversation oh what that was not where
we're headed we're not excited oh my god
this
i feel like i'm in a ron popeil
infomercial for physics
but wait there's more wait order now
order now you'll also receive okay here
we go you ready what's the bonus
okay so let's raise the temperature
some more let's make it um
85 degrees let's make it 90 degrees
outside
all right it's 90 degrees okay that's
still cooler than your skin temperature
okay it's still cooler all right
so you'll feel that amount of heat i'm a
little uncomfortable
i whatever but the air is still pulling
heat out of your body right okay but not
but but you
you know what 90 degrees should feel
like when you walk out there okay right
so watch what happens
now a breeze comes so whatever rate 90
degree air was taking heat out of your
body
right it will now take heat out of your
body faster
because a fresh pocket for the same
reason we're talking about wind chill
factory except we don't
call it wind chill factor in the
summertime
we call it a cool breeze we call it
refreshing
we call it a cool breeze but that air is
the same temperature as the air
that was there before you had the breeze
right so it's not the breeze is not
cooler
not at all no the breeze isn't cool
i am baby
[Laughter]
so our vocabulary changes from wind
chill factor
to cool breeze right but it's still it's
still a chill factor it's still making
you cooler
yeah that's great it's the same
temperature air coming across your
your body right the same temperature air
okay
yeah except the problem with that though
is that weathermen will feel like
dumbasses when they go you know and
we're looking at a high of 97 with a
wind chill of 93.
exactly that would be perfectly
legitimate
right okay nothing wrong there right
okay so
and while we're there let me add this
there are two ways
you can feel hot one of them is
you're not losing heat as quickly as you
should okay
another one is you're directly receiving
radiant energy from the sun
okay directly so photons moving through
the atmosphere and impinging on you
right this is enhanced if you wear dark
clothing
okay dark clothing absorbs all the
sunlight right white clothing reflects
most of it
right okay i have a skin suit of dark
clothing
there you go right so that's why the
clothing colors would
generally changes from summer to winter
right okay you want to stay cooler in
the winter warmer in the summer
you wear lighter clothes in the summer
reflecting this radiant
energy that's trying to get in your body
and vice versa in the winter so now
watch
let's say you're out on a at a baseball
game and
no it's a little league game and you're
there and you're out in the bleachers
and it's hot
and you say i gotta go where it's cool
so you get up and you go under a tree
in the shade in the shade okay
the air in the shade is not
necessarily and is hardly ever cooler
than the air that's out in sunlight
right because air mixes very very
definitely there you go okay but you say
it's cooler
because what you have done is subtracted
away the radiant heat hitting you from
the sun
right that radiant heat is not
participating
in the temperature of the air the air is
transparent to the radiant heat it's why
you can see the sun in the daytime
okay air is transparent to sunlight
so going under the tree the air is the
same temperature
you're subtracting away a source of heat
that is the sun itself
right and then when a breeze comes you
got it it's margarita time
more creative now it's margarita time i
got shade i got a cool breeze
okay which is not even a cool breeze but
wait there's more uh oh here we go
okay all right the reason why you
sweat is
i've been caught
[Laughter]
that's different okay so
if you sweat there's a bead of sweat on
your body right okay
now the beta sweat is about the same
temperature as your skin
okay the breeze blows across your sweat
and across your skin your skin will feel
cool
that's fine but what that warm air will
do
to the bead of sweat is
have that bead of sweat participate in
taking heat out of your body because it
requires heat to evaporate
and your body's hotter than the air so
where's it going to get the heat to do
this
your body okay these we're talking about
cases where
you're 97 degrees and the air is like
low 90s okay
so so the bead of sweat now says i want
to evaporate
i will take heat from your body to do
that
and to evaporate a bead of sweat takes
more energy
than just the energy that's pulling out
of your skin from moving air
gotcha that's why
when you sweat and then have a breeze
across you
it's way cooler than if you didn't sweat
you ain't lying that's fonzie cool right
there but that's funny
that's fonzie cool and in fact in theme
parks where everybody's got to wait
online they have these sort of mr
misters there yes
that if you're not otherwise sweating
it'll put water on your on your body
without you having to have sweat it
there that water then evaporates and
then you feel cooler
that's excellent okay so your body does
this to cool down
more effectively all right so now here's
the problem
if we're almost almost all the way there
if it's high humidity uh-oh
sweat has a hard time evaporating right
because there's no moisture in the air
there's moisture in the air and it's
trying to compete it's trying to get
into the air where there's already
moisture
all right and it's a contest between who
can put the moisture in the air if the
moisture or
the air already has moisture so you
start sweating the breeze comes
it has a hard time evaporating the sweat
okay
so the sweat just stays and you feel
dank
you feel hot you feel wet you are
uncomfortable
and so they have this they have a heat
index or something it's the ability of
your body
to cool down under those conditions and
the lower the humidity
the better able your body is to
accomplish this nice
okay so now we're ready for the
final offer okay
what happens if the air temperature goes
above your skin temperature
oh if your air at the air temperature is
a while skin temperature let me say you
explode
[Laughter]
so watch what happens now now the air
blows across your skin
but the air is hotter than your skin so
your skin is saying hey i want to
cool you down so your skin
takes heat away from the air and puts it
in your body
well if your skin is absorbing heat from
its environment
rather than giving heat to the
environment you instead of feeling cold
you will feel hot
so we go from a wind chill factor
to a wind heat factor gotcha
that's why when you open an oven and the
flowing air comes out you don't feel
cooler from that you feel hotter
have you ever been behind a jet engine
when it turns on you feel hotter
okay that air is hotter than your skin
temperature it's a wind
i've had that experience okay i don't
stand behind jet engines
but i'm gonna take your word for it so
it's a wind heat factor that's why
if the temperature goes above your skin
turning on a fan
no gotcha fans are
bad when the temperature is above your
skin chemicals because watch what
happens
watch what happens watch what happens
when you sweat so now you sweat your
butt i'm going to sweat so i can cool
down
the bead of sweat is there on your arm
hot air blows across it and the sweat
says hey i can evaporate
by taking heat from that hot air so it
evaporates
using heat from the air instead of heat
from your body heating you up even more
even more not only that it's also
dehydrating you
oh so you are losing liquid and
heating up in the presence of moving air
that's hotter than your skin temperature
so they have found old people in homes
where if the air conditioner breaks and
they put on a fan
and the temperature rises they're
dehydrated and they're dead
from um heat uh heat exposure
yeah and one of those is a real problem
it's just
so the whole range of what happens when
air blows across your body
we have different terms and different
ways of thinking about it but it's the
same
phenomenon it's which what
direction is heat going when
the when you put two two surfaces or two
uh media in contact with one another wow
that is
now this has become something that's
very very useful we started out just
you know learning some stuff but this is
really people should really look at this
especially since our summers are getting
hotter
and we're having more days than ever
that are above 100 degrees
this is really useful information now
yeah yeah and so
and there it is that's why in the summer
you should always drink a lot of water
because your body's trying to cool you
down
right sweet so there it is
you heard it here chuck always good to
have you man always a pleasure
this has been star talk neil degrasse
tyson here signing out
as always bidding you keep flipping up